[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après faute c'est du passé par ailleurs
comme vous je vais faire s'en fiche
c'est pas tes fiches c'est pas à toi ça
suscite émoi lundi de l'arrêt nice et
qui sait la personne dieu bénisse
que dieu bénisse ces me remplissent le
compte en suisse pour l'instant c'est
bien ça transpire de petits suisses cola
ça commence à marcher c'est la dernière
de la saison
oui c'est accueillir ses chroniqueurs il
faut prendre chaque jour comme le
dernier oui ok eh ben espérons que ce
soit pas le cas aujourd'hui c'est les
meilleurs moments de l'indic cyril on a
réuni douze mois oui on a réuni les plus
gros dossiers non c'est sûr vous aussi
nous écoute pas oublier toutes les
dossiers oubliés à une seule et unique
histoire qui marche
c'est encore une fois que je vous
rappeler aux téléspectateurs qui se
passe quelque chose avec the albatros
que sa chaîne base à 11 ans et donc sa
maman à l'âge de guillaume genton et la
maman de séchelles base et guillaume
genton se sont rencontrés en voiture en
voiture
et depuis est-ce qu'on peut rater avec
ça ils se sont jamais lâché mais j'aurai
qu'on fasse un petit récap de l'histoire
j'ai une chronique affaires syriennes et
facétieux la france at on indiqué moi je
te dis que t'as pas trop a dit essaie
d'envoyer l'image
comment un petit récap sur l'histoire de
nos jours rien garder cette semaine la
famille des pmp s'est agrandie et contre
toute attente c'est le petit elbaz qui
est concerné c'est pareil vous avez
draguer sa mère ce week-end non celle du
madrillet sa mère a pris mon [ __ ] à la
passe naples et dans son cocon yaro de 9
4 sur 5
la rumeur annonce une idylle entre
caroline sa maman et guillaume genton ni
chroniqueur me dise où on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une belle histoire
[Musique]
sacha ne voit pas d'un très bon oeil la
venue d'un nouveau beau papa ça peut
être mon beau-père regardez le malgré
les encouragements des autres
chroniqueurs
quel est le souci que ta maman qui
justement n'est plus avec ton papa brink
est une femme libre
on évite une vie de femme épanouie
partir en famille parce que yom il ya
une vraie responsabilité vidéo
sexuellement et de syrie grandir c'est
comprendre les envies de sa maman cette
histoire ira-t-elle à son terme
moi je croyais plus en l'amour j'ai
rencontré carreaux je ressens des choses
que je n'ai pas ressenti qui vont à la
suite de ça un film verra-t-il le jour
mais surtout carreaux et guillaume vont
ils réellement se pécho des repas divers
invités à dîner après l'émission
réponse ce soir dans touche pas à mon
poste si je suis car on nous regarde
qu'est ce que vous avez à lui dire ce
soir là bas rouergue bondissement parce
que je n'ai attendu au restaurant hier
soir elle n'est pas venu non pas nous
restons hier soir c'est peut-être parce
qu'elle avait envie de vous voir ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu fais là j'aimerais qu'on
est ce qu'on peut asseoir madame monique
robin maire serge paolini a même annoncé
au prix je crois que c'est la maman
death et la mort de guillaume un peu du
to play merci non mais maman m'a dit
maman tu en sais pas si ils font face à
un moment j'ai une chronique tu sais je
cherchais n'y aura pas de poignée de
carolis et vous mais c'est ma mère reste
encore à le prouver
sai baba même chéri les chéris guillaume
genton oui je te sens tout ému mais je
suis très amoureux aujourd'hui j'ai
écrit un petit mot m
pour caro dans ces nouvelles lire ce
soir c'est lourd caroline les gens qu'on
va faire connaissance avec leur ligne
merci d'être là peut-être la maman de
sacha giffa pas qui vous êtes une femme
avec un grand f c'est ma mère avec un
grand m
non mais vous savez qu'un bref comme ça
randol décerne notamment caroline ce
soir première question que vous posez
c'est est-ce que vous êtes venus pour
voir sacha ou pour voir guillaume
pourquoi les noces oui bon voir ses
chats merci maman c'est que c'est un peu
pour voir les deux oui un petit peu pour
ne fait pas de commentaire non bien alex
est amer cyril c'est ma mère c'est pas
parce que c'est à dire que nous allons
voir mais on va rentrer ensemble ce soir
et on va manger
guillaume elle en fait j'étais
tranquillement aux voitures jour en
séance d'uv équipe caroline qui est une
femme sublime m'a interpellé m'a dit je
suis la maman d'un droit c'est vrai
c'est vrai ou pas oui c'est vrai pendant
que je suis là monde sache à qui je dis
je suis ravi de vous rencontrer j'ai
laissé ma carte de visite
elle m'a envoyé un petit message est oui
j'aimerais d'ailleurs moi j'écoute je
pourrais me après j'ai un droit de
réponse quand même alors comme le dit mc
solaar je suis las de trèfle qui pique
ton coeur pierre
[Applaudissements]
ce soir je suis las de trèfle qui te
pique ta mère sache ah oui tu va
appliquer ma main dans ta gueule tu
adores reprend reprend on parle j'ai vu
c'est magnifique
j'en fais depuis le début alors je
compte sur toi tu as vu ma voiture aux
moi quand je t'ai vu ce sont mes joues
qui le sont de nouveau ce soir tu es
face à moi et je peux enfin te le dire
car aux haïtiens la première fois que je
t'ai vu je lui ai tout de suite su toi +
moi égale plein de nouveaux sacha jeu
mais je vais être vulgaire mais très bon
la fin à sa série alors car au monde
dans mon auto vous font sur moi pour
t'ouvrir le capot bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
on va se retrouver là tu vois pas en
train de tomber sur un homme riche si tu
vas y vas t'on faire plein de cadeaux
mais je m'en fous des cadeaux comme
gentil s'il vous plaît cinq radios on
peut voir à quoi ressemble guillaume
genton s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors ça va être capturé
tu as d'ailleurs parce que j'ai cette
barrière je suis tu sens très bon c'est
mon moteur tu peux aller s'asseoir et
savoir si je suis pas là bas car c'est
mon staff a été exceptionnel une fois de
plus mon sacha d'amour tu sais je t'aime
ça fait des années que je travaille toi
j'ai toujours voulu le meilleur pour
tous ouais mais là c'est pas le meilleur
pour moi
guillaume citigroup c'est guillaume
caroline s'exprimait qu'en version vous
allez vous exprimer caroline et c'est
vous qui allez décider de l'avenir de
sacha déjà de l'avenir d'accord et de
l'avenir de l'amour en france je m'égare
dans le fait d'être maman l'amour avec
un grand a
comment douillette dans un instant chaos
et le dire si vous souhaitez pas partir
guy avec guillaume ou séparément
je peux vous donner la réponse au dessus
est un succès caroline jeu alors je veux
où on va vous demander de se retirer du
marché
alexis partenaires et d'eau et mettez le
parce qu'incarcéré l'eau caroline vous
êtes magnifique en tout cas mr cyril et
sasha est une très belle réussite
ouais un travail r oui mais c'est une
très belle personne malgré tout ce que
peut dire le pew en plus il y en a ils à
guillaume laborde bien six pistons
ce soir à 19 heures 47 pour cette
dernière de tpm paix l'amour à frapper à
notre porte
[Musique]
on est de grands espaces
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un échec
elle est avec nous c'est caroline
caroline c'est la maman de sacha face à
el baz je crois que vous peut dire je
crois que c'est 2018-2022 sa carrière
s'achève base qu'elle indique de la red
hat et malheureusement mon sacha d'amour
qui sera avec nous l'année prochaine
avec ou sans maman sacha ta maman a eu
le bonheur de croiser guillaume genton
indien ou genton aujourd'hui c'est plus
de 15000 euros par an après c'est plus
de 150000 euros de beauté capillaire par
semaine et c'est plus de 200000 euros
le visagisme et par mois bref il
françois louis quoi il prend sans lui
mais aujourd'hui et il y en a marre de
prendre soin de lui tout seul il a
besoin de quelqu'un et il a jeté son
dévolu
sur caroline la mère de sacha way sacha
s'en prend ta garçon génial mais sacha
aurait également besoin d'autorité et
malheureusement je ne suis pas là le
soir viennent heureusement donc fait
preuve d'autorité avec lui de 8 heures à
19 heures mais après il est livré à
lui-même est un beau gaillard comme ça
il a besoin d'une poigne de fer 7 poigne
de fer est là elle est représentée
aujourd'hui par petits groupes où j'ai
gagné rollin' déjà première question la
caroline 7 vous
un coeur à prendre
non c'est avec quelqu'un ça ne commence
et avec quelqu'un déjà pris tu ne vas
pas dit quoi mais parce que bon
finalement est ce que vous croyez
très amoureux c'est quoi ça c'était
guillaume parce qu'elle me dit sur
snapshot certaines personnes sur ce
plateau de guillaume qui savent en baby
qui n'existe pas il pense avoir une
drague qui n'a jamais eu lieu d'être
en fait s'il a souvent envie de lui dire
niktamère vraiment mais cyril fait
penser qu'on peut aller ensemble
véritablement moi je trouve magnifique
abbas est gentil et guillaume genton
mais on trouve à neutre vous êtes le
soleil caroline il peut être votre
parasol
j'ai déjà mon grand soleil
c'est vrai oui c'est s amedi lui ce que
tu en penses
est ce que ça aurait peut être votre
style absolument pas
[Rires]
carton d'audience avec juste frotter la
troupe se faire une protection dont on
parle de ma mère est-ce que tu prends tu
veux faire une croix dessus non mais on
parle de ma mère ta mère tu sais oui
elle sait se démerder tout seul non
madame canada maman c'est non non vous
pouvez dire à la france la presse m
vous allez guillemin déjà chez qui est
déçu mais a été déçue je vais rentrer
dans une phase de reconstruction
[Rires]
l'adorent non mais quel est ce monde
rez-de-chaussée est bloqué sur snap
déjà qu'on ait un ce n'est pas entre
nous dit pas c'est autre chose
merci car on va voir si les 30 secondes
oui trente secondes parce que oui justin
voulait je crois que vous avez raison
parce que bon on a un petit truc on à la
première télé maintenant oui et non
c'est encore pire que çà mais jeanne et
serge marquis maintenant c'est à dire
que ouais j'en marque money c'est vrai
c'est guy roux jean mermoz et aussi ses
membres et ouais pourquoi il s'est
énormément de respect pour lui et je
l'embrassé au kivu d'aborder très grand
will avait il prévu d'annoncer plus loin
de vous c'est clair que pour lancer une
année magnifique à ce sujet allant voir
la première télé de guillaume genton je
me permets de prendre 10 secondes pour
vous remercier parce que grâce à vous
chaque semaine la en ce moment chaque
soir je réalise mon rêve
une partie de mon rêve et c'est grâce à
vous donc merci beaucoup et l'indic vous
voyez ma tête mais ne la co star très
sobre mais où il ya un truc tu ne le
doit qu'à toi non victimes on verra ça
vous y voilà c'est grâce à vous je
remercie toute l'équipe et surtout lundi
que vous voyez ma tête et mes co star un
peu chelou chaque semaine mais derrière
il ya une équipe il ya un cap ou bep cap
à mal l'idée d'un producteur à des
logiques de la vie lauriane fabien de
l'être tout est breton voilà donc c'est
toute une équipe qui bosse der lundi que
ça demande beaucoup de travail donc je
voulais vraiment leur faire un gros big
up
[Applaudissements]
mais son cas sébastien bach de risques
en cas lionel stan évidemment toute la
direction un stade comble si je peux
avoir un petit billet en plus à regarder
les plantes ont regardé parce que il m'a
bien cherrier semaine c'est ma part j'en
sais sur ma chaîne étudiante je crois la
télé est à vous et sans tabous soyez les
bienvenus dans libre antenne aujourd'hui
on va s'intéresser un thème qui concerne
beaucoup de jeunes à savoir les
mutuelles étudiantes alors couvre-t-elle
suffisamment leurs affiliés pourquoi
ont-elles fait parfois l'objet de
scandales dans l'actualité pour en
parler je reçois mais il damon mb
bonjour alors juste avant de rentrer
dans le jeu des baisses on peut rappeler
qu est ce que c'est qu'une mutuelle
étudiante je pense que moi et je pense
que tu devrais sais pas comment ça fait
deux semaines que je te dis de faire
cette coulée laisser dire ça mais tant
qu'on écoute moi bonne chance avec un
lacet laurent delahousse de we show si
vous étiez sur une île déserte
vous n'êtes plus avec votre mec vous
devez partir avec un chroniqueur partait
avec qui rien qu à manger tous les
permis c'est bien dans mon rugby sachant
que tu connais il avait déjà viré
pernikoff à carreaux pardon je vois bien
pernikoff ah d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m